les banque d'investissement, ou les cours en ligne.
Comme moi, ils ont passé au moins un an et des centaines d'heures à observer,
interroger et même travailler côte à côte avec les personnes qu'ils étudiaient.
Nous avons partagé nos données, et j'ai cherché des tendances.
Peu importe le secteur, le métier, le type d'IA, l'histoire est la même.
Les sociétés travaillent dur pour obtenir des résultats de l'AI,
et ils écartent les débutants de l'expertise par la même occasion.
Les start-ups sous-traitent leur service client.
Les policiers doivent apprendre à anticiper la criminalité
sans le support d'experts.
Les banquiers débutants sont exclus des analyses complexes.
Et les enseignants doivent créer leurs cours en ligne seuls.
La conséquence de tout cela est la même qu'en chirurgie :
apprendre sur le terrain devient de plus en plus difficile.
Ça ne peut pas durer.
McKinsey estime qu'entre 1 million et 1 million et demi d'entre nous
devra apprendre à utiliser des IA dans son travail quotidien d'ici 2030.
Et nous assumons que l'apprentissage sur-site
sera toujours présent pour nous pendant la transition.
Le dernier sondage d'Accenture montre que la plupart des employés
a appris les points-clés de son métier sur le terrain et non en formation théorique.
Alors tandis que nous parlons de son futur impact éventuel,
l'impact le plus important de l'IA actuellement,
est la façon dont nous l'utilisons aujourd'hui
et qui gêne l'apprentissage sur-site,
alors que nous en avons justement besoin.
Mais parmi ces exemples, une petite minorité a trouvé une solution.
Ils ont brisé et détourné les codes.
Les méthodes classiques ne fonctionnaient plus,
alors ils ont changé les règles
pour pouvoir pratiquer avec des experts.
En chirurgie,
des internes se sont spécialisés en chirurgie robotisée à l'université,
au détriment de leur éducation générale.
Et ils ont passé des heures en simulation ou avec des enregistrements vidéos,
au lieu d'apprendre en salle d'opération.
Et plus important encore, ils ont trouvé le moyen de s'entraîner
sur de vraies opérations sous supervision limitée.
J'appelle ça « l'apprentissage fantôme » parce qu'il change les règles
et que l'étudiant pratique dans l'ombre.
Et tout le monde laisse faire parce que ça marche.
Et ceux-là sont les meilleurs des meilleurs.
Evidemment, ce n'est pas bien, ni même viable.
Personne ne devrait risquer un licenciement,
pour apprendre ce qui est nécessaire à son travail.
Mais nous devons apprendre de ces gens-là.
Ils ont pris des risques pour apprendre.
Ils ont compris qu'il leur fallait tenter et se challenger au travail
afin de progresser vers des tâches plus difficiles
et de repousser leurs limites.
Ils se sont aussi assurés d'avoir un expert non loin
pour les conseiller ou éviter les catastrophes.
Construisons cette combinaison de pratique et conseil
dans les IA !
En voilà un exemple découvert sur le terrain :
avant les robots,
un démineur désarmait un engin explosif en s'en approchant.
Son élève se trouvait à 50 mètres,
et ne pouvait observer et aider que si c'était sûr,
et que le démineur l'y invitait.
Maintenant, ils sont côté à côté, dans un camion blindé.
Ils regardent ensemble l'écran vidéo.
Ils contrôlent un robot à distance et le maître explique à voix haute.
Les élèves apprennent mieux grâce aux robots.
Nous pouvons étendre cela à la chirurgie, aux start-up, à la sécurité,
aux banques d'investissement, les cours en ligne et au-delà.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que nous avons les outils pour ça.
Internet fait que nous n'avons pas besoin d'un maître pour chaque étudiant,
ni qu'ils soient physiquement au même endroit, ni même de la même organisation.
On peut construire des IA pour aider :
pour coacher les élèves quand ils galèrent ou coacher les maîtres qui enseignent,
et pour connecter ces deux groupes intelligemment.
Il y des gens qui travaillent sur de tels projets,
mais ils sont surtout concentrés sur l'apprentissage théorique.
Et le plus gros soucis est l'apprentissage « sur le tas ».
Nous devons faire mieux.
Les problèmes actuels exigent que nous fassions mieux.
Que nous créions des tâches exploitant toutes les incroyables capacités des IA,
tout en améliorant nos propres compétences.
C'est le genre d'avenir dont je rêvais plus jeune.
Et c'est maintenant qu'il faut le créer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)